blue prism is one of the top rpa
platforms
it is a software that develops
enterprise robotic process
automation allowing businesses to
automate complex and end-to-end
operations
hey everyone i welcome you all to this
video
in this video we will learn about
installation of blue prism
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon
so you never miss an update from simply
learn so without wasting any further
time
let's get started go to the browser
and browse to blue prism portal
go to the blue prism portal login page
if your new user go to sign up here
and enter the email address user name
password
and confirm the password scroll down and
enter the first name
last name job title country
and fill all the required details and
solve this math question
and then create a new account
since i already have an account i'll
click on login
and i'll login
so once once you sign up you will
receive an
email go to your email id and
check the email go to your inbox
and check the email which you have
received and open the email
and you will receive a link click on
that link
click on the link then go to the product
go to blueprint of enterprise
and go to the edition which you want to
download so we'll download the learning
edition
so click on the learning edition and
then click on
download 64-bit
so here you can see that the download
has been started
so it's getting downloaded so when this
software is getting downloaded you will
receive an license key
so go to your inbox and go to your spam
folder
and check for the license key so here
you can see
we have received this license key
so this is this attachment this is the
license key
so download this license key and here
you can see
the steps have been written how you need
to download
so once this is downloaded we'll open it
when it is done so now we are installing
the blueprism software
so first click on get started
the next license agreement check the
license agreement and
click on next then check the location
this is the default location
if you want to change your location you
can change will keep it as default and
click on
install here you go the blueprism
software is getting installed
so we have installed a blue prism on our
machine
click on finish and launch bluepriser
so the blue prism is getting launched
and the next step is we need to create
the password so create a password the
login password which you
want create your own password after
creating the password click on save and
continue
and then click on next building
databases
once the database is complete
installation is done
click on next blueprism learning edition
opens
enter the admin username and password
which we created in the previous steps
enter the username admin and password
click on sign in using blue prism
credentials so enter the part to the
license key
go to your email id and go to your spam
folders
in which you have received the license
key
so browse there and select the license
key then click on next
you have successfully activated the blue
prism license key
then click on next to launch the
application so the blue prism
application is successfully launched
click on next so it will give an
overview about the home page
and the studio control room
and digital exchange go through the
overview
and that's it you have successfully
installed the blue prism learning
edition
so with that we have reached the end of
this video like and share it if you
found it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here